sex kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem kleinen ankündigungs video das
wird heute kein richtiges video weil ich
es zeitlich nicht mehr geschafft habe
aber ich wollte ich einfach nur bescheid
sagen was in den nächsten tagen bei mir
los ist damit euch nicht wundert falls
eventuell keine videos kommen wir haben
jetzt 13 30 mit nämlich das aufnehmen um
14 uhr muss ich das wird zeitlich wieder
ein bisschen nach österreich fahren dann
bin ich bis sonntagabend also heute ist
donnerstag besonders tagt bis sonntag
wenn ich dann in österreich ich habe
aber für alle fans die hacker sofort
produziert das habe ich geschafft heißt
die hacker schock kommt ganz regulär am
sonntag was morgen mit dem bios los ist
weiß ich noch nicht
ich hatte geplant dass ich dann aus
österreich da bin ich übrigens mit max
also kein crafter peterle und gysi dass
ich da aus österreich fällt noch ein
zwei blocks machen das war so der plan
werden wir dann sehen ob das klappt das
internet soll angeblich nicht so gut
seien die leute schon gemeint ich diesen
schon vor mir da unten um ja deswegen
ist noch mal schauen aber auf jeden fall
wollte ich schätze mal es ist jetzt zwar
kein richtiges video und wahrscheinlich
haben sich ein paar richtig ist wieder
gefragt aber ich finde immer wichtig
dass ihr so wissen was abgeht bei mir
deswegen die info ich bin in österreich
bis sonntag erschoss vorproduziert
ansonsten schaue ich dass ich ein zwei
blocks bringe das was war eigentlich
schon ich muss jetzt gerade noch also
ich muss eigentlich eine halbe stunde
losfahren muss vorher noch die hose und
ski unterwäsche kaufen
briefe zur post bringen und das auto
betanken und den reifendruck checken
das wird sehr sehr eng deswegen will ich
jetzt gar nicht zu viel erzählen hier
leute wenn irgendwelche fragen zu dem
thema könnte die und in den kommentaren
stellen ansonsten sehen uns
allerspätestens am sonntag wieder mit
der neuen folge hacker show und am
montag dann mit regulären videos
wahrscheinlich aber noch mit blogs
dazwischen
das was du mir peace out over and over
österreich